bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur arte france alors le
syndicat uni affirme que deux
restaurateurs sur trois pourrait mettre
la clé sous la porte d'ici la fin de
l'année
d'abord est-ce que vous vous partager ce
sentiment et comment vous faites face
aussi à la situation et certains
essayent de exemple et c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué emmener loin confinement
est légèrement moins en moins de monde
alors l'union des métiers des industries
de l'hôtellerie donc l'umih qui déposent
un recours contre le décret
gouvernemental
ils dénoncent une inégalité de
traitement par rapport à la restauration
collective est ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire un peu plus sur cette inégalité
je pense que c'est vraiment deux poids
deux mesures quand on regarde et
d'études c'est certain si vous prenez
des personnes me demander ce qui est sûr
que 9 personnes sur 10 ou à louer la
halle des sports c'est vrai que c'est
totalement illégal ou l'air ou mais est
ce que vous pensez tout de même que les
restrictions prises aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement par rapport à votre corps
de professionnels aujourd'hui ça peut
être efficace pour lutter contre le coc
vide 19 sera sûrement efficace mais la
rue problématique c'est que d'accord
permet nuit mais par contre payer le
coût la réalité c'est que doit
aujourd'hui on est au bilan nous permet
héros et en a les crocs structure un
ipad en fait peut-être aura un impact
sur mance vous permet il y aura un
impact mais surtout en vue qu'on nous
oblige à fermer
la problématique est qu'aujourd'hui le
commerce meurent parce que alors avant
justement les mesures gouvernementales
avant seront confinement et la fermeture
des restaurants des bars et des cafés
justement il y avait quand même un
protocole sanitaire précis suivi dans
vos établissements ce que vous pouvez
vous dire aujourd'hui que sous protocole
vous pourriez par exemple le renforcer
et si oui comment ne pas totalement on
peut le rendre mais 90% des répondants
odieux commis distanciation chaque table
le gel hydroalcoolique jetables le mas
on allait au maximum respecté que
sanitaire c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
peut y accéder on peut être un miroir du
ray mais nous préparons à la
problématique des restos et les imports
ont montré du doigt en disant que le
comique est parti un à ces
établissements sont ouverts donc je
pense qu'on peut lui
tous ont augmenté de lever les
restrictions sanitaires
si on ouvre ici on pense pas que
forcément les établissements sont la
première cause le premier curseur pour
le pôle comédie le premier ministre a il
a déjà prévenu que les bars les
restaurants ne devrait pas rouvrir au
1er décembre ne pas rouvrir pour à cette
période festive qui s'annonce c'est ce
que qu'est ce que ça implique pour votre
profession la mort des gens jettent
était esseulé qui allait manger de
l'outil condamne les récents mais
surtout on ne rit pas franchir
si on nous dit regrouper en trois mois
on arrive à retravailler certains
restaurateurs ont modifié de manière
travaillez donc leur manière d'une
serviette mais c'est vrai qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui tous les quinze jours on
n'arrive pas à se positionner il à
savoir réellement où on va dans le temps
en fait ce que je pense du bouc même
récemment c'était voilà trois mois
en somme une solution pour imposer des
prêts et on avance mais quinze jours et
par conséquent par l'élection de mai
nous s'est rapidement s'il vous plaît
est ce que vous vous sentez soutenu par
les pouvoirs publics au niveau de dz
en fait on est soutenue si on arrive à
comprendre cette dette qui arrive d'être
égaux à ceux dont la non n'est pas
soutenue on a en a 10 500 euros sont
assurés si on perd c'est important de
refaire mais à part ça ne passe que les
commerçants à chacun ce qui est celle de
l'établissement qu'ils ont c'est le
remboursement au moins de notre charge
de x
c'est vrai que sans les charges fixes
mais on n'arrive pas à avancer et tout
ce qui les loyers de tout ce qu'on a en
charge depuis que parce que lui donnent
les 50% de la fin de l'année sur notre
charge d'un coup fin des chantiers mais
ça reste des textes n'ont pas à ce jour
mais on espère un jour qu'ils nous
disent merci beaucoup à vous jean pierre
scarfone de nous avoir consacré un peu
de votre temps je rappelle que vous êtes
restaurateur à nice merci beaucoup à 9